oh why am I operating the untested
nuclear laser you have the longest arms
this is just a little bit of grounding
so you don't die immediately you have
done this before right right hey fire
we've been waiting for the longest time
for this Ghostbusters reboot and I want
to ask you does it answer the age-old
question of this busting make you feel
good yes it does Justin I actually
thought this was a really fun movie my
expectations were kinda low going into
this but you know I came out of it
really enthused and I guess you know the
main thing is I want to see more I want
to see more of these new characters I
want to see where they go with it and I
think you had a good time too I was very
trepidatious after watching the trailers
the they made it seem like a movie that
was just going to be funny and silly and
not have any of the weird gravitas of
the first movie and that wasn't the case
at all like I loved these characters it
had a very Disney like sense of horror
and I mean that in a good way that it
was very creepy and spooky like going
into the haunted mansion but at the same
time fun it was a ride from beginning to
end and the new characters were great
like Kate McKennon I think totally sold
it I didn't really know her going in
this film but every time she was on
screen just the expression she would
make made me bust out laughing just give
it a punch its motion activated and I
think Chris Hemsworth was the other
breakout star in this I mean he plays
this really sort of almost too dumb to
be believable character but he just does
it so well and for me he was one of the
highlights of the film like you know in
the theater that we were seeing this
with you know like nearly every long
he'd got a huge laugh which i think you
know we both liked it but I think a lot
of people out there asking you know how
does this actually compared to the
original film it's got a very very high
bar to actually try and reach right yeah
and we're going to go into some heavy
spoilers so if you haven't seen the film
you probably don't want to listen to us
talk anymore but I thought some of the
cameos that they did I really enjoyed
them they do a lot of callbacks to the
original film both in the pacing of the
film in the in the way that things are
set up but also characters who show up
you you see
original Ghostbusters not in the
original roles but I really enjoyed that
as fanservice you know Justin you're a
smart guy but I think completely wrong
in this I actually found those cameos
really really distracting um you know I
think you know a few of them I think for
example Bill Murray I don't think it's
really a spoiler to say he's in his
films I think he's been out before but
you know his role was actually pretty
well conceived he was integrated well
but there was some others in there that
were just absolutely shockers like dan
aykroyd one was just atrocious was not
that but it was really bad and when you
know when everyone sees it in the
theaters they're gonna like grow and as
much as I did when I first saw that
thing and I think this is you know this
this sort of goes to the heart of you
know like the key thing that I feel is
lacking in this film and that is when
you do compare it to the original it
doesn't it doesn't compare very well and
sadly I think the film sort of does that
to itself like it it sort of echo story
beaten even echoes sort of lines
directly from the first film and when it
does that you just get reminded about
the original Ghostbusters and how great
that movie was and when you hold the two
up together this new Ghostbusters film
just isn't as good like it's a fun film
and it's a great you know a couple of
hours in the cinema but when you do you
know start looking at it you know
looking at them side-by-side it's just
not that good a film especially in that
second half the first half was so funny
that once they come together that second
half it just feels like it slows to a
crawl and it really kind of defines its
own internal logic in the first movie
had made sense that you'd have the Stay
Puft Marshmallow Man yeah it was a
character they're going up against it it
has an obvious weakness if you burn it
it's gonna fall apart as made of
marshmallows yeah in this one they had a
huge monster who comes up at the end who
I guess he can also feel pain in and get
hurt and it didn't really make sense how
they were fighting these ghosts all of a
sudden they were using contraptions that
were made to trap ghosts they could
throw them around but apparently they
could also disintegrate them and none of
that really made sense in the context of
the film yeah like the actual settle
like the ending action sequence of this
film kind of felt really weird if a
Larry video gaming yeah within the
ghostbusters universe because suddenly
you know the ghost but cesare just
by coming up with is like you know cool
new weapons to destroy ghosts and
apparently you can destroy it goes by
just slam and get into a car now so it
did all these like you know really sort
of strange like you said video gave me
things like it looked cool like it was
all in slow motion and have you know the
Ghostbusters Rock theme you know going
on so you know it was good to watch but
it kind of felt a little bit off and and
you're like I feel the same as you do
like the first half of this film was
great you know when they're setting up
all the new characters when they're
setting up you know this new world and
you know how they're trying to become
the ghostbusters it's all good but after
that when they actually after they catch
their first ghost basically I don't have
to concentrate on the plot I don't think
it worked as well and I think it's
because like the big bad guy in this
just isn't anywhere near as threatening
as you know Gaza was in the first
Ghostbusters film ya go sir was such a
serious threat like there were a lot of
jokey monsters Slimer like everything's
just kind of yelling at you but then you
got to go sir like the states were
raised so high but in this one all the
enemies were kind of jokey up until the
very end yeah and like you know goes are
in the first one yes it was a comedy
film the first ghostbusters but goza was
always feeling very seriously I know
anyone you know anytime anyone talked
about dozer it was in hushed tones and
how he was to destroy it is gonna be the
end of the world and all that sort of
stuff so you know when he finally came
around you took it seriously in this
film you know the big bad is this so
like poor put-upon loser right but is
made fun of throughout the entire film
you know when he eventually you know
gets his power at the end you still
don't take him that seriously so you
know that whole threat of you know the
apocalypse and all that sort of thing
never really played out that well for me
but it does set up this film I think for
for like future installments and I'm and
that's the thing I'm most excited about
so the Ghostbusters would you know is
such a beloved movie that it didn't feel
like something that needed a sequel or
needed an extension much less needed an
entire reboot with a completely new cast
do you feel like this movie redeemed
itself do you feel like it's necessary
now to have this new goes but yeah and
that's the thing like it this film you
know had a lot of online hate I'm you
know for various reasons you know a lot
of it you know people would say is that
you know
was it was this reboot necessary you
know like what was it necessary to just
completely scrub the old Ghostbusters
because this new film you know takes
place in New York but doesn't
acknowledge that you know the original
film ever happened in fact the originals
will never happened in this in this
film's timeline in that way you know I
think this really does work you know and
you know I'm sort of speaking more from
you know as someone who you know want to
take my son to this thing right so this
film is gonna be his ghostbusters you
know what I mean I'm it might be my
daughter's ghostbusters as well so you
know I've had my I'll always have very
fond memories of the original I even
like ghostbusters 2 I thought that was
pretty cool you know and you know even
though this doesn't match the highs of
that original film for me I'm quite
happy for a whole new generation to
discover Ghostbusters and you know that
whole concept of you know like this team
of paranormal experts you know with
high-tech weaponry going out and taqman
ghosts that's a cool concept you know it
doesn't need to have Bill Murray in it
if you just have funny people doing
awesome things and I'm okay with that
how about you yeah and they made
references to the outside world and in
some ways to comments made in message
boards yes but the end of the day they
they just ignored a lot of that stuff
and just let the characters be
themselves and they were just cool smart
fun characters and I think that's the
most important takeaway is that it
doesn't matter who the ghostbusters are
if you have good actors portraying them
and good writing which they did
especially for the first half of this
film it doesn't matter like I loved
going back into the Ghostbusters world
yeah bottom line for me is you know
design the old ghostbusters but that's
cool these are new Ghostbusters and I
like them too
oh no it's like Marty run